بحلول الوقت الذي استجابت فيه قوات الأمن في
الساعات الأولى من صباح يوم الأربعاء
، كان قد فات الأوان
اغتيال الرئيس الهايتي جوردانيل مويس
في
مسكنه الخاص زوجته ، السيدة الأولى في هايتي ، أصيبت بجروح خطيرة في
الطب الطبي للولايات المتحدة من أجل
العلاج المحتمل المنقذ للحياة
مع بزوغ فجر النهار  في أعقاب
ثقوب الرصاص وأغلفة القذائف ،
كان نطاق الهجوم الوقح أكثر
وضوحًا ، والمعلومات التي لدينا هي أن
المهاجمين كانوا مجموعة من
الأشخاص الذين يتحدثون الإنجليزية والأسبانية
وكانوا يحملون أسلحة من العيار الثقيل
وقتلوا الرئيس
هذا الصوت المتداول على  تزعم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أنها كانت في وقت
الاغتيال
رغم أن CNN لا يمكنها تأكيد صحتها
مدعيةً أنهم نحن
عملاء إنفاذ قوانين المخدرات ،
وتقدم أدلة حول كيفية
تمكن المهاجمين من اختراق الحدود الأمنية
المحيطة بمقر الإقامة الرئاسي ، على
ما يبدو بسهولة السفير الهايتي.
لنا
قوله في مؤتمر صحفي يوم الأربعاء  يُعتقد
أن المسؤولين اليوم
هم مرتزقة مدربون تدريباً عالياً
يتظاهرون بأنهم
عملاء لنا ، وقلت إنهم عرّفوا عن
أنفسهم على أنهم
صماء ، ولهذا السبب
قدموا هذا هو السبب في أنهم قدموا
أنفسهم
على أنهم الوكيل كما لو كانوا هنا لعدم وجود
عملية دكتوراه ،
هل تعتقد أنهم كانوا في الواقع  دي لم
يكن هناك أي طريقة كان من
الممكن أن يأتي العام
وكان سيتم إبلاغ الدولة بهذا الشكل
وكل ما
يفعلونه دائمًا مع السفارة الأمريكية ومحطات الطاقة ،
كما ترفض وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
أن
المسؤولين  يمكن أن تكون هذه
التقارير كاذبة تمامًا.
تدين الولايات المتحدة هذا
العمل الشنيع ، هذه التقارير الكاذبة
ليست أكثر من مجرد تقارير كاذبة
حيث أن مطاردة المشتبه بهم المتورطين ،
قال سفير هايتي لدى الولايات المتحدة في
وقت متأخر من يوم الأربعاء إن أربعة مشتبه بهم
يُزعم أنهم على صلة بالاغتيال
قُتلوا على
أيدي الشرطة الوطنية الهايتية بينما
تم اعتقال اثنين آخرين
قال السفير إن الستة كانوا جميعًا
أجانب ، لكن جنسياتهم
لم تحدد بعد
، وبقية رئيس وزراء الدولة بالإنابة
الذي تولى
قيادة البلاد في
محاولة لطمأنة السكان المذهولين
وكذلك زعماء العالم
بأن حكومة هايتي لا تزال
تعمل
حالة الحصار التي
تسمح بإغلاق الحدود الوطنية
وتطبق الأحكام العرفية مؤقتًا ،
نريد أن نؤكد لكم أننا
سنقدم قتلة الرئيس
إلى العدالة ، يرجى التزام الهدوء والسماح
للسلطات بالقيام بعملها.
بلد تغرق في
الفوضى ،
هذا يوم حزين للغاية
لأمتنا ولشعبنا في الحياة كان الرئيس الهايتي جوفينيل
مويس شخصية مستقطبة مع
احتجاج الكثيرين على
حكمه وطالبوه بالاستقالة وترأس
دولة على حافة
الفوضى السؤال الآن  على الرغم من أن موته
سيدفع الأمة إلى ما
وراء نقطة الانهيار مات أنهار
CNN